so in terms of the reason of Suspicion
yeah again I have a huge problem with it
irrespective of Andrew Taylor he was in
a situation where he there was lenience
in the in leniency in the law that was
error on his part but it doesn't mean
that just because someone makes a silly
decision and assumes that certain laws
you know that is unaware of the the
legalistic system in a certain country
that he should then the harshness of it
we should ignore as well in terms of the
harshness of it the reason why we have
Civic severe issues is because it's I
can understand why you may not
understand it but people from the
minority Community who have been abused
and terrorized by these laws they
understand what the problem is